la icónica plaza de bolívar en la
capital de colombia era el punto elegido
pero no hubo encuentro con el gobierno
nacional
la minga que congrega a miles de
indígenas representantes afro y
campesinos colombianos llegó hasta el
lugar cercano al palacio presidencial
buscando dialogar con el jefe de estado
estamos prestos al diálogo con el
gobierno pero no por lo tanto seguiremos
en línea de resistencia
piden al gobierno garantías para que se
acaben las matanzas de los integrantes
de sus comunidades y de otros líderes
sociales de acuerdo con la organización
indepaz 47 líderes indígenas han sido
asesinados en el último año y la cifra
asciende a 167 durante la presidencia de
iván duque además del derecho a la vida
porque los indígenas aseguran que
numerosas zonas quedaron desprotegidas
tras la desmovilización de la guerrilla
de las farc con el acuerdo de paz lo que
ha llevado a violentos enfrentamientos
entre grupos de narcotráfico disidencias
de las farc y otras organizaciones por
el control de esos lugares pero
y sigue negándose a reunirse con los
manifestantes nada justifica que en
estos momentos pongamos en riesgo la
salud y la vida
si tenemos discusiones demoras en el
marco la democracia
así que tenga que haber emplazamientos y
ultimátums ni invocar juicios que no
tienen asidero este miércoles la minga
se unirá al paro nacional convocado por
las centrales obreras para exigir el fin
de los asesinatos de líderes sociales y
que se acabe la represión en las
protestas
[Música]